tell me about how you're in the
illuminati what
because he's part of it dude he's part
of like you know the whole clinton mafia
yeah
so uh write the whole thing down my pops
do you not know this
you haven't heard about this you don't
subscribe to the clip's channel she
doesn't know anyway he's bona fide
illuminati no what yes i take back my
engagement ring
you just wanted to show off the ring
oh i take back this ring
um
my dad was kind of like a low-level
democratic operative like uh you know
helping people's campaigns early on
in the early 90s 90s
he was an alderman yeah in the city of
nashua new hampshire you know
this is what it is kind of like as low
as you could really be on the local
governance totem pole but he was doing
his thing and he wanted to be mayor or
something he figured he could turn it
into something we have a real skeptic on
our hands too
can we bust out some conspiracy uh
corner oh right now hold on hold on
wait for it
and
action okay
okay as you were as you were mr 22 okay
he okay new hampshire
low-level operatives right yeah you kind
of have to win new hampshire in the
primaries at least then if you wanted to
have a shot at winning the presidency
it's kind of important then to be right
cooperative in new hampshire right he
was clever enough or lucky enough to
serve on bill clinton's uh first
election campaign you know in new
hampshire helped him win new hampshire
yeah probably realistically didn't play
that bigger role probably not probably
you know yeah
[Laughter]
my dad caught a charge a federal charge
for uh mail fraud because he allegedly
was using his role as an alderman to
basically get the construction company
that he was employed by
work get jobs what's an alderman for us
dummies it's just basically like a
really really low it would be like a
senator for a tiny municipality helping
to make decisions whatever you know and
uh
he allegedly was using his power to
get this
get more work for his his boss
uh the way he told me is basically that
like the feds wanted to get his boss
and that he wouldn't snitch on him so he
ends up having to do a plea deal he does
one year in federal prison around 1995
and then when
talk right
when bill clinton
when he leaves office
bill clinton issues a series of
presidential pardons as they do he
issued like 30 i think 40 pardons of all
the people that bill clinton met in his
life that went to prison
he chose to pardon someone who was
already out of prison
but it made it so that he was no longer
a felon and he could vote which was very
important to my dad
wow
i helped him kind of clear up his
name there i would assume my dad has uh
you know not talked to bill clinton
since or probably before that for like
maybe 10 years but has he been on the
plane
there's been a lot of talk of that i
don't know he never knew uh he never
knew epstein he never went to the island
oh my gosh you're hearing this for the
first time i'm just like like the plane
somebody
somebody made a youtube video about them
in the illuminati you know you know it's
a fun i thought it was just because your
last name hadn't based on that that
probably is grand
mason like they're not even hiding it
they're audacious
yeah it does mean big house but who's
invited to the big house yeah should i
not change my last name when we get
married no you haven't been thinking
about avoiding it and that is how you
will join the illuminati and then i'll
get to tell you about all the cool [ __ ]
we got going on
that's how he has the connections to all
these different people do you remember
the stone cutters
the masons no the stone cutters from the
simpsons no damn why i go no just like
homer had like a bull a giant boulder
chain do them and [ __ ] was like the best
episode ever when you could drive
underneath the whole city they cut
traffic oh really it's like you find out
in the episode that everybody in the
whole town is in the secretive group
called the stone cutters the stone
cutters hilarious
this is this awkward thing we tell
somebody about a really funny episode of
a tv show
they're not cultured in any way so they
have no idea what you're talking about
and then we just project the
insecurities
when you two are walking around new york
who gets noticed more frequently hmm
really
i didn't have someone else end of the
plug when i was on the phone with my dad
though and i was like her content is
kind of secretive not even that like
they can't run like we had daisy taylor
on the podcast you know daisy taylor
she's a trans porn star right and it's
like she said like people will notice
her and then make like a knee-jerk
reaction to be like daisy and then catch
themselves because they're admitting
they like transport so like i imagine
people notice you and they're about to
be like glenna and they're like with
their girl and they're like oh yeah does
that happen a guy will see you and be
like
like double take three times it did
happen to me the other day and then the
guy saw me later and was like i like
your work but like you're youtube too
it's okay trying to be supportive
it's it's i just like i like yourself
what is the best way to be a porn fan
yeah how do you compliment a porn star
the best i think just saying hi i like
your work is totally fine when you're
like kind of weird and like oh my god
like just don't get is aggro when they
start telling you how hot you are yeah
don't tell me where that happens that
happens in front in front of you like
you are the hot no not in front of me
but like
at the porn convention yeah there's some
fans porn convention and you see all
kinds of all bets are awesome i feel
like an elephant tamer when i'm at the
store
because i'm like walking her around and
rushing through like groups at the end
guys
it's so weird yeah but i know i'm
halfway famous because i see a ton of
people googling me right in front of my
face they'll look up yeah yeah they'll
be like at a distance on their phone and
glancing up at me and i know i know
they're googling me and like kids come
up to me with like youtube with like
they'll search no jumper and they'll be
like this is you
and that's always kind of weird i'm like
i mean it's cool it's nice but it's
i know it's not 100 clicking with them
no it's clicking yeah a little click
they know what it is now have you ever
been asked if you're a waiter because
somebody recognized you but didn't know
where from
wait what what like sometimes people go
like they're breaking they their brain
is just trying to understand right like
how they know you so they position you
as another job and then they go oh no i
watch you and your wife [ __ ] oh no not a
waiter does it happen to you yeah like
different jobs well you look much more
like a waiter than he does well is this
a jacket
is it yeah
[Music]
[Music]